rehab the most common place to go after
hitting rock bottom
other than Dave & Buster's don't let
their smiles fool you every one of those
men is at the lowest point in their
lives in that photo
now rehab is a place where people can
address an addiction to drugs or alcohol
something that until relatively recently
was seen as a moral failing that could
be overcome with sheer willpower perhaps
best epitomized by this amazing PSA from
the 80s
starring singer Belinda Carlisle I used
to do drugs and one morning I woke up I
looked in the mirror and I said you look
frightening I got sick of it so I quit
and now the beach rat now incidentally
Belinda Carlisle has since admitted that
after that PSA was shot she used cocaine
for another 20 years to a point where
and I'm quoting her directly here I'm
surprised I still have a nose which is
the kind of statement you only normally
hear from toddlers who just spent the
afternoon with their uncle he he told me
he got it did his fingers and I
flipped man I was crying screaming the
whole thing I'm surprised too still
after those right no thankfully
thankfully there is now a broader
understanding that addiction is complex
and that nothing about getting off
alcohol or drugs is easy experts now
view addiction as a medical problem
often lock into a disease or a chronic
condition and a common way of treating
it is through stints in rehab
it is a thirty-five billion dollar
industry with over 14 thousand rehab
facilities across the United States some
of which have fancy names like promises
or passages or milestones you know names
that sound like perfumes worn
exclusively by widows and some rehabs
can even afford to run TV commercials
like this cliffside Malibu has been
helping people just like you for over 12
years
except most insurance our experienced
compassionate staff will help you get
your life back call the number or go to
the site below now don't wait because
your tomorrow may never come wow that is
a hard turn there
that's like frosted flakes ending a
commercial with Tony the Tiger getting
shot by poachers now now in recent years
it has gotten easier to get insurance to
pay for rehab that's largely thanks to
the fact that george w bush passed and
Barack Obama expanded laws requiring
health insurers to increase coverage for
its but while we use rehab as a
shorthand it is worth knowing that there
is no set definition for what it should
consist of in fact there are no federal
standards for counseling practices all
rehab programs and while many really
halves are staffed by people doing their
best to help a report a few years ago
found that the vast majority of people
in need of addiction treatment do not
receive anything that approximates
evidence-based care and for a sense of
just how bad things can be look at
Florida a state whose rehab industry has
seen an epidemic of overdose deaths and
fraud to the point where one local
official issued a chilling warning the
clear message would be stop sending your
loved ones to South Florida because
we're sending them back in body bags
holy that is the worst
and yet possibly most honest tourism
slogan for Florida I've ever heard come
to South Florida we'll send you home in
a body bag so tonight let's look at what
rehab is and why the industry so
troubled and let's begin with the fact
that rehab should never be seen as a
quick fix it's often just the first step
in a lifetime of recovery yet many
operators make huge claims about their
success rate take passages in Malibu the
father and son who run it make some
pretty big promises about what they can
do for you when you send patients home
what do you say to them you're cured
totally cured 100% you will never use
drugs and alcohol again right your
dependency has been cured have a
wonderful life
for a start there is no way when
patients leave this doesn't say
ciao
there is no way that sound
doesn't come out of his lips but it's
not just passages lots of rehabs feel
free to make suspiciously impressive
claims as one researcher found out we
called inpatient programs and ask them
what their success rate was and the
lowest rate we got quoted was 80% you
know I do know that about 80% of clients
who have come in here are now sober long
term we've had about an 80% success rate
here at 180 and then we would ask and
one what data do you base that and no
one had any data they had no hard data
to back up their claims and at that
point why even stop at 80% why not say
you have a one hundred and forty percent
success rate for every ten people that
come into our facility 14 emerge
completely sober where did those extra
four people come from we have no idea
that's how good we are and that's the
thing rehab success rates are often
based on self-reported statistics
involving them simply calling former
clients and those results can be
problematic as a man who's participated
in one of those studies can tell you
they call you up and they ask how you
doing and you just lie you know
fine you know I was drinking yeah I mean
it's it's crazy you know but I was
embarrassed to say you know I didn't say
sober I mean kind of understand that for
every reason it can be hard to admit
that you've relapsed plus it's a phone
call so you'll say whatever it takes to
make it end because getting sober may be
hard but nothing is harder than an
8-minute phone call with another human
being nothing nothing at all and look
for all those claims of success it is
very hard to know exactly what you're
getting at any given rehab you might get
the traditional 12-step based approach
which undoubtedly works for some
although most experts argue that there
should also be consistent access to
other newer treatments like certain
behavioral therapies or medications like
these but rehabs are not required to
offer those and because a rehab can
essentially be whatever
it's proprietor says it is that means
they can frame almost anything as
treatment for instance many high-end
rehabs offer something called equine
therapy and again if people respond to
that that's great but there is no
empirical evidence that as a treatment
for addiction it works which means some
people who paid a high price for it can
end up having this experience they had
like the whole equine thing I mean you
go and pet horses what is
petting horses gonna do for me
let me do two a goddamn thing I don't
even like horses okay so first
of all I absolutely love that guy second
of all he's completely right horses can
go straight to hell why do we even need
them anymore
I'm sure you could ride one somewhere or
you could just drive the car which is
like a horse except it can play music
and it doesn't constantly
everywhere you're an idiot patches an
idiot now one of the places one of the
places that offers a coin therapy is
cliffside the place from the ad that you
saw earlier now a month of treatment
there cost tens of thousands of dollars
and its founder Richard Tate gets a
little defensive when asked if it's
worth that price
listen seventy three thousand dollars
sounds like a lot of money but if you go
to the Four Seasons for thirty days okay
that's gonna be forty grand right okay
what did you get
was there any life-changing thing going
on there everything that we've done here
is mindful it only seems like horse
to people that don't know better but you
don't have to know better bro because
your life didn't depend on it
you didn't go through it okay calm down
bro besides you being a little unfair to
the Four Seasons plenty of life-changing
things happen there just last year Jaden
Smith claimed that the one in Toronto
spiked his pancakes with cheese after
kicking him out of his room and if a
handful of Canadians tricking into an
addicted Charles millionaire with
undisclosed ricotta isn't a
life-changing thing I guess I don't know
what is anymore and $73,000 first 30
days does sound like a lot of money
because it is a lot of money and you
would hope that at cliffside they could
account for every moment of treatment at
price but that does not seem to be the
case where your where your patients at
today I don't know where are they
where'd they go no you're not Bub's here
I have no idea I have no idea okay no
idea do they they probably went to
whatever they did there's a therapeutic
meaning behind it good site bro
because you were in trouble for a minute
there
but the therapeutic meaning line was
absolutely inspired because the truth is
anything can have a therapeutic meaning
his patients are stroking horses that
could be therapeutic they're biting owls
that could be therapeutic
even the act of them being lost could be
therapeutic
it's called inadvertent wilderness
therapy and it's a hundred and forty
percent successful
look so far we've just talked about the
fancy high-end residential facilities
but there are oversight problems
throughout this system because in many
states the barriers are opening a rehab
can be dangerously low for example in
Idaho as long as you are not operating a
residential program for adolescents you
don't need a license at all in
California as long as you take private
pay clients anyone can start an
outpatient rehab center and in Florida
if you want to open a sober home a group
home where people stay often while they
receive outpatient treatment there is
nothing in state law to stop you
technically oj simpson could open one
right now which would obviously be
called the juice cleanse and there would
be nothing standing in his way and
florida actually provides a window into
how the flood of insurance money into
treatment centers has caused massive
problems because the industry boomed
there and unscrupulous operators have
found it way too easy to gain the system
take urine testing insurance covers drug
tests and some places have exploited
that arranging for kickbacks from
testing facilities basically meaning the
more you're in they take the more money
they make and it adds up fast for a
single thirty dollar store-bought urine
test you could get up to five
$1,800 in payouts from insurance
companies so let's do the math if you
run five tests a week on a single addict
that's seventy five hundred dollars six
addicts at five tests a week $45,000
that's over 2.3 million a year exactly
urine is so valuable that in the
recovery industry it is known as liquid
gold and peeing liquid gold
sounds like the symptom of an STD you
can only contract from c-3po no
see I don't think all women born after
1990 have it anyway unless you're
sleeping with all women born after 1990
see are you are you doing that see
you're a dog see you're a metal dog and
with money like that to be made just
from urine it is hardly surprising that
some operators have gone to extreme
lengths to attract patients with
insurance even engaging in something
called patient brokering or junkie
hunting here is how that works
Mercedes Smith the recovering addict
herself told us sober home operators
compete for addicts with good insurance
enticing them with promises of free rent
free food free cigarettes we would have
to drive around Delray and anybody with
like suitcases we would have to ask them
do you have insurance
any place we can go okay so in terms of
questions to ask people from the window
of a moving vehicle do you have
insurance is barely less sinister than
would you like some candy or what size
of flesh are you
and it gets even grimmer because the
truth is there can be more money in a
patient relapsing than in them
recovering so at its worst
this system encourages a cycle of
admission relapse readmission and
relapse again this cycle even has its
own special term it's called the Florida
shuffle and if you are not extremely
lucky this is how it ends
in the Florida shuffle you go in and out
of recovery in and out of rehab centers
in and out of sober homes milking the
individual for their insurance until
that person dies yeah the Florida
shuffle turns out to be horrific and not
as I'd assumed a party where everyone
throws their keys in a bowl and gets to
go home and their neighbors
alligator and if at this point you're
thinking well I guess I just need to be
extra careful when I'm looking for
treatments well that is the final big
problem here because it can be nearly
impossible to find good unbiased
information let's say you're sitting at
home and you see this ad which plays a
lot we are the addiction Network and if
you have a problem with drugs or alcohol
you need to call the number on your
screen now addiction is a disease and
you can't go it alone the call is free
and so is the consultation so why
haven't you called why haven't you
called that is a hostile tone that you
would not tolerate elsewhere Tampax
tampons why isn't one in you right now
seriously
explain yourself but the important thing
to understand is that the addiction
network is not a rehab it is a referrals
business meaning they make money by
routing your call to centers all over
the country which reportedly paid them
forty to fifty dollars for your call so
in a moment of crisis your individual
circumstances are not being taken into
account
they're simply placing your fate in the
hands of whoever has $50 which is a
terrible system I have $50 but I have no
idea how to treat someone with an
addiction I'll probably just give them a
copy of my handmade anti-drug pamphlet
titled napping with the devil please
stop doing heroin
and if you're thinking now well hold on
I wouldn't fall for a sketchy looking TV
ad or I'd do my own research that is
great but let's say that you saw that
cliffside ad and you thought well that
looks good but I do want to check it
myself first well a Google search will
quickly land you on rehab reviews calm
which says that cliffside is the choice
for those that have to have the finest
of everything or you might land on the
de fix comm a whose review of cliffside
raves that it is a great choice for
anyone who has the means to recover
their what you probably won't see on
either of these websites at least not
unless you know exactly where to look is
that both of them are actually owned by
Richard Tate the founder of cliffside
Malibu you remember the guy who looks
like Matt Lauer a pair of oakley
sunglasses and that fact that fact the
fact of ownership certainly casts some
doubt or on the fact that the fix
awarded cliff side a rating of five out
of five stars presumably one star for
every ten patients whose location he's
completely unaware of and let's say
someone you love was truly in crisis and
you wanted information on cliff side
from an outside source like what
complaints had been lodged with the
states and what the state found when
they investigated well in order to get
that information you would need to file
a public records request with
California's Department of Health Care
Services and then wait four months for
them to send you what could be a huge
pile of documents to sort through and
that is too long to wait for urgent
information it's akin to a pregnancy
test that takes you eight and a half
months to get the results that is
practically useless and a huge waste of
perfectly good urine which as I now
understand it is liquid gold
everything about this industry is
incredibly difficult to navigate which
is dangerous because even one of its own
trade groups its own trade groups has
warned that some sectors of it are out
of control and for a sense of just how
helpless you can be in the face of all
this just listen to Tom McLellan he was
Obama's deputy drug czar
you would think that if anyone knows
this world it would be him well guess
what I had become an expert in the
addiction field and then my son became
addicted and I had no idea what to do
all that training all that knowledge
about addiction did not prepare me for
the most fundamental question of all
where do you send your kid for treatment
it's true even the nation's deputy drug
czar couldn't confidently navigate this
system and the tragedy is his son died
and remember the funny guy who hated
horses he died too so this is a matter
of life and death and if you if you're
wondering what experts would advise you
to do in seeking treatments many that we
spoke to suggested beginning not with a
rehab which may try and sell you on its
own services but with a doctor who is
board certified in addiction medicine
now it's only recently become an
official specialty so there just aren't
many of them around but you can find
those that do exist at this website here
they may be able to guide you toward a
treatment that best suits your needs
which might well not be a fancy center
where you have to pay seventy three
thousand dollars to have this guy lose
you look look this system clearly badly
needs more expertise and oversight and
until then it may be really important
for all of us to understand that at
present the word rehab is so broadly
defined as to be close to meaningless it
is honestly barely better defined than
the word building and and if someone
were to tell you I have a drug problem
but don't worry I'm going to building in
Florida you would naturally say hold on
what's building where did you find this
building what's happening inside it is
it a hospital or a hooters
or both is it is it a hoot spittle what
what what's the proof that it works and
watch the doctor to horse ratio like in
there
and sadly right now it can be way too
difficult to get answers to those
questions which is crazy because so much
about battling addiction is really hard
getting clean is hard staying clean is
hard but getting good evidence-based
trustworthy help should be the
easy part and right now it is way too
easy to literally wind up pissing money
up a wall
you